- From the moment I heard
my next guest's music,
I was a fan, my mom actually
showed me her record
and I love her.
I even performed her song, "You Say"
for our first show in quarantine.
Her music is very necessary
for these times, any time,
but it's especially important right now.
So let's bring her in here.
Hi, Lauren!
- Hey, Kelly, hey!
- I know the last time
we ran into each other,
we were at dinner.
- You were.
- But I'm such a fan of yours
and I hope the shows at
the Greek went really well,
but you had to postpone your tour, right?
So when do you plan on
kicking that back off, 2021?
- Yes we start back again in 2021
and I am so ready, I'm
telling you, I miss,
it's like everybody on the
road becomes your family,
you know, they're like your people
and so just being apart and being away,
I'm like, "How much longer?"
I feel like every day feels like
it's 30 hours, not 24 hours, you know,
it's like every day that goes by, gosh,
I miss the people, I miss the environment,
I miss the energy of
being able to just sing
and have people experience
something collectively together.
I miss the environment and
I miss my friends, you know.
- I get it, so tell me about
the song you're gonna
perform, it's called "Rescue".
- "Rescue" is probably one
of the most personal songs on the record.
I remember writing it
in mind of a loved one.
And the thing about it is,
I don't know if this has
ever happened to you,
where you write a song
but it's almost like
the song writes you before you write it,
I don't know if that makes
sense, but it's like,
especially for times right now,
like especially with what's going on,
it's like that song
couldn't have been more real
and more potent for such a time as this.
But it's like you're experiencing it
with every other person who's listening.
But, yeah, I don't know
if that makes sense,
where it's like, you write the song
but the song really writes
you before you write it,
like it's an experience
that is yet to be had,
like you're about to have that experience
but you don't even realize it
and you're just writing and you're writing
and you're enjoying it
and then all of a sudden, it's like,
"Whoa, this became real." you know?
- I agree, I agree.